por fin hemos llegado a uno de mis temas
favoritos en todo el cálculo multi
variable y es la divergencia y en los
próximos vídeos voy a describir qué es
matemáticamente y cómo calcularlo pero
aquí simplemente quiero dar un
entendimiento visual de qué es y tratar
de representarlo así que tenemos una
imagen en frente de nosotros es un campo
vectorial y como he dicho antes es una
forma muy bonita de entender digamos
cómo cómo fluyen algunos fluidos como el
agua o el aire verdad y lo que quiero
hacer es pensar en cada punto de este
espacio vamos a pensar que es una
partícula verdad quizás una partícula de
aire o de agua y lo que un campo
vectorial hace es asociar a cada punto
en el espacio un vector verdad y
recordemos que cuando representamos
campos vectoriales solo mostramos un
pequeño subconjunto de sus vectores pero
en principio podríamos estar pensando
que todos estos puntos infinitos en el
espacio tienen un vector asociado y de
hecho digamos son cambian cambian de
forma suave a medida que atravesamos el
espacio verdad lo que significa que
tendremos un pequeño digamos una pequeña
muestra
finita de toda esa infinidad de vectores
y aún así nos da una muy buena idea de
qué es lo que está pasando así que si
tenemos partículas de un fluido verdad y
tenemos un vector asociado a cada uno de
ellos una idea natural que podríamos
pensar es qué pasaría si dejamos que
esto avance con el tiempo verdad donde
en cada instante del tiempo verdad la
velocidad de esas partículas está dada
por el vector que que tiene asociado en
ese punto verdad así que a medida que se
mueve estará tocando un vector distinto
así que la velocidad quizás podría
cambiar un poco girar verdad ir en otra
dirección y cada molécula va a recorrer
una trayectoria determinada por estos
vectores verdad cuando los tocan y
podríamos pensar que todo esto lo
hacemos en un solo momento verdad se va
a sentir justamente como un fluido y en
realidad no tienes que imaginar lo que
ha hecho la animación para ti
así que pongamos algunas moléculas de
agua o puntos que representan una
muestra de moléculas de agua verdad a lo
largo de todo este espacio y vamos a
darle vamos a correr esta animación
donde cada una de estas se está moviendo
siguiendo el vector que está más cerca a
él así que corremos
pasión y aquí vemos que cada partícula
está moviéndose a lo digamos siguiendo
al vector que está tocando en el punto
en donde se encuentra en dado momento
verdad así que por ejemplo si regresamos
digamos a la imagen verdad y quizás
enfocamos nuestra atención en sólo un
punto verdad digamos este punto que
tendrá un vector anclado aquí verdad se
moverá en esta dirección pero sólo por
un instante porque justamente después se
va a mover un poco y tendrá otro vector
ha anclado verdad así que si corremos la
animación y seguimos ese punto
particular después de un poco lo
encontraremos en otro lado verdad creo
que era creo que era justamente este y
ahora tiene otro vector verdad anclado o
quizás era otro punto en realidad no
importa pero si pensamos en todas estas
partículas al mismo tiempo verdad esto
nos da una idea global del campo
vectorial si estás estudiando
matemáticas podrías empezar a
preguntarte algunas dudas inmediatas
sobre la naturaleza de este fluido por
ejemplo podrías tratar de contar el
número de moléculas de agua que hay
dentro de esta región verdad y ver si
este
esta cuenta cambia con digamos con el
tiempo verdad mientras corremos esta
animación y en este ejemplo particular
puedes ver que en realidad no cambia
mucho verdad no incrementa ni disminuye
a lo largo del tiempo verdad así que si
te doy una función que determine este
campo vectorial deberíamos poder ser
capaces de decir porque en este caso el
número de moléculas en la región no
tiende a cambiar mucho pero si nos
fijamos en otro ejemplo digamos este de
aquí y si nos enfocamos en lo que ocurre
alrededor del origen verdad podríamos
predecir incluso qué es lo que va a
ocurrir verdad una vez que dejamos que
estas moléculas de agua que voy a poner
fluyan siguiendo los vectores verdad
entonces la densidad dentro de la región
va a disminuir verdad así que ponemos un
montón de moléculas corremos la
animación por un instante y vemos que
algo que caracteriza a este campo
vectorial alrededor del origen es que
disminuye la densidad de verdad entonces
esto nos sugiere bastante el tipo de
operación que vamos a estar haciendo
aquí que tiene que ver con las moléculas
de agua y es que éstas tienen que
divergen
alrededor del origen es decir el tipo de
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial
será positivo verdad y esto lo que
significa matemáticamente lo veremos en
otros vídeos así que si ahora volteamos
los vectores de aquí verdad si los
volteamos ahora nos preguntamos sobre la
densidad en esa misma región alrededor
del origen y probablemente vemos que
incrementa verdad justamente cuando el
flujo avanza en realidad no divergen
sino que convergen hacia el origen y
este hecho tiene un significado
matemático para la función que
representa a este campo vectorial
alrededor del punto incluso si el campo
vectorial no representa a un fluido
verdad no puede representar un campo
magnético o un campo eléctrico o cosas
de ese estilo verdad hay ciertos
significados para esta idea de divergen
desde un punto o converger hacia un
punto ya veces algunas personas en lugar
de pensar en un campo vectorial que
tiene un flujo que se aleja verdad desde
algún lado en realidad en vez de pensar
en que disminuye la densidad también se
puede imaginar que este fluido tiene
digamos una
forma de reproducirse nuevamente
alrededor de este punto así que
podríamos pensar que el origen es un
cierto tipo de fuente de este fluido
verdad y si animáramos esto mejor
tendremos un montón de puntos que serían
que estarían surgiendo desde nuestra
fuente verdad así que en realidad la de
la densidad no disminuye en todos lados
pero la idea es que los puntos de donde
hay divergencia positiva verdad tendrían
una especie de fuente de este fluido
para que las cosas se sigan manteniendo
igual es verdad y al revés si estamos
pensando digamos en un flujo que va
apunta hacia adentro en alguna región
verdad lo que podríamos llamar una
divergencia negativa entonces al correr
esta animación podríamos ver cómo es que
continuamente tendríamos que en el
centro digamos en este punto central
verdad tenemos un sumidero o un pozo
verdad y podríamos pensar que este
fluido se escabulle por algún lado
verdad este es quizás un término muy
técnico verdad algunas personas dirán
que el campo vectorial tiene un
pero si regresamos al ejemplo original
donde no teníamos un cambio en la
densidad del fluido lo que podríamos
notar es que esto realmente se siente
más como si fuera agua verdad que los
otros ejemplos y justamente es porque no
hay un cambio en la densidad así que si
encontramos una forma matemática de
describir esta falta de cambio en la
densidad es una muy buena forma de
modelar el flujo del agua verdad y otra
vez no es que sea un flujo de agua pero
es algo que a lo mejor podría ser un
campo magnético o puede tener cualquier
otro significado verdad el punto es que
no cambia la densidad o una idea similar
verdad así que yo creo que con esto
hemos avanzado bastante en los próximos
vídeos te voy a contar qué es la
divergencia desde el punto de vista
matemático cómo calcularlo y haremos
algunos ejemplos nos vemos